welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and we've got fresh new trailer
footage for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Mutant Mayhem coming to theaters August
2nd 2023 Our Heroes at a half shell
haven't been on the big screen since
2016. I've missed them and I personally
can't wait to see them make their
triumphant return this summer so grab a
slice of pizza and your favorite martial
arts weapon and let's dive into the
mutant Mayhem but before we do don't
forget to check out nerd Riot dot shop
where you will always find the latest
and greatest in new rockstars merch all
right let's hit the sewers
boys Where Have You Been
we're just running errands that's it
oh
we're really sorry Splinter some of the
guys wanted to get pizza and I tried to
talk them out of it you ratted us out
don't use that word that way I mean
so the trailer opens with Leonardo
Donatello Michelangelo and Rafael
flipping and running all over New York
City's rooftops we get our first look at
Splinter voiced by Jackie Chan he's
asking the boys where they've been in a
worried parental tone and just look at
how cute that giant Ninja rat is he's
sitting in a leather armchair what looks
like a number one dad mug on a floral TV
tray with this classic purple robe
oversized glasses and white whiskers he
just looks like such a dad Splinter is
Daddy the turtles were lying to him
obviously and you just know that he's
not mad he's just disappointed turns out
they were filming themselves on their
phones doing cool ninja stunts just like
regular teenagers shout out to my
nephews always filming stunts but sweet
rule following Leonardo doesn't have the
stomach for lies and gives up the ghost
I personally am glad to see splinters
taking the word rap back it's about time
for all of us rat bastards also the
turtles confirm that this is the year
2023. we love a current timeline we cut
to the Green usified Paramount and
Nickelodeon logos and can I kick it by A
Tribe Called Quest starts to play as we
get look at the New York City manual
cover leading down the sewers now
remember a lot of this was similar from
the teaser trailer we got back on March
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
[Music]
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat the
turtles refer themselves as monsters
shunned by Society the official
description of this film says after
years of being sheltered from the human
world the turtle Brothers set out to win
the hearts of New Yorkers and be
accepted as normal teenagers whether
that means Society has actually shunned
them or maybe their pop Splinter is just
trying to keep them safe we're gonna
have to find out about that but don't
shun those little Ninja Turtles come on
executive producer Seth Rogan has
emphasized that one goal of this movie
was to make it more than just your
typical action film saying we found a
way to make it deeply personal it's a
teenage movie We're putting a lot of our
own fears of awkwardness and insecurity
and a desire to belong and be accepted
and all that into the movie now I get
that insecurity awkwardness doesn't just
stop at teenage years boys you can be 38
and be awkward you guys are up late
talking in their bunks the clock shows
that it's 2 54 a.m must have been a late
night of crime fighting we get a look at
their very messy room among the Clutter
there's a planted Hollywood mug a Super
Soaker on the ground and a Target board
hanging on a pipe with a score sheet
underneath we also see Raphael's size
stick out from the underwear drawer each
Turtle has some Flair in their bunk that
shows some of their own personalities
Leonardo has a poster for secret ninja
Roaring Tiger a Korean martial arts film
from 1982. it was directed by Godfrey ho
a director from Hong Kong who is
believed to have directed around 100
different films under different names 80
of those films being made between 1980
and 1990. now that my friends is a quick
turnaround a lot of people ask me how
I'm able to stay focused
researching all these vids and honestly
it's this
I can feel the energy surgeon one shot
Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
everybody really even hunks like me they
make Energy Chews and focus chews the
focus shoes are my go-to but it just
depends on what you need each energy
shoe has 75 milligrams of pure caffeine
plus 600 milligrams of additional
nootropics to give you a serious energy
boost that works immediately as you chew
Look at me now I just chewed I'm
practically jumping out of here Focus
Shoes now available in limited edition
new Rockstar steam packaging really help
me concentrate and give me a natural
boost of energy with B C D and E
vitamins if there was an F vitamin
they'd have it too plus zinc to help
with immune system support and the amino
acid tyrosine both energy shoes and
focused shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to oneshotenergy.com new rockstars
for 10 off your order
one shot
Donatello has a globe and stacks of
books next to his bed as well as a model
of the Space Shuttle and a computer
monitor with icons on the desktop that
are a complete mess come on organize
those icons make them into files we get
a shot of them flying out of the sewer
like the opening to one of their many
cartoons and they meet up with April
O'Neill to share their exploits we see
them fighting human criminals in a candy
factory underground poker room pool hall
and noodle restaurant always convenient
to beat your enemy in a place where you
can get a snack after and finally we get
a shot of some pizza it looks like the
pizza has pepperoni which makes sense
and also white dots that look like
marshmallows this could be a nod to an
episode of the 1987 cartoon where
Michelangelo requests this specific
Pizza much to splinters discussed Master
Splinter perhaps you'd like to try some
pizza it's marshmallow and pepperoni the
boys again prefer to Splinter his dad
really showing how young these Turtles
are they have referred to Splinter as
father before in previous iterations of
TMNT like the animated 2003 and 2012
shows and the 2006 the movie but the use
of the word dad just makes it feel extra
emotional it also makes them feel extra
young these are teenagers after all you
start baffled by the recent crime wave
led by a Superfly nobody's ever seen his
face why because he kills everyone who
does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out
Superfly and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us we get a
look at April's investigation board in a
dark room tinted with red light the
board reads who is Superfly with
locations of connected incidents pinned
throughout NYC there are newspaper
clippings with one showing a picture of
a giraffe and a headline containing the
word Heist more on those giraffes in a
moment another clipping shows a fence
that has been busted open clearly some
crimes involving some animals there's
also something in a biohazard bag along
with a candid photo of a man walking and
a list of other potential suspects the
turtles see taking out these criminals
as their chance to become Heroes and
therefore accepted by society and we see
versions of them that look like how we
all drew them when we were kids how do
they know that one of those things where
everyone in the world drew them the
exact same way there's a shot of the
Manhattan Bridge the Brooklyn Bridge's
less popular cousin with the NYC Skyline
in the background including the Freedom
Tower which means the turtles live in a
similar universe as ours we then meet
the mutant Brotherhood of this film LED
by Superfly who has a vanity license
plate that says Superfly bold move is a
villain from left to right we have
Genghis frog voiced by Hannibal Burris
Leatherhead by Rose Byrne Bebop voiced
by Seth Rogen Superfly voiced by Ice
Cube Rocksteady voiced by John Cena Ray
filet voiced by post Malone and an
unconfirmed bug creature that I think is
scumbag he has similar yellow bloodshot
eyes the antennas the pincers he's also
wearing the remains of a shirt as he
often does in the other Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle stories we have Mondo Gekko
voiced by Paul Rudd Wingnut voiced by
what we do in the shadows Natasia
dimitro we will probably get their
origin story as we see tiny little
creatures in a test tube with use a
gecko a rhino a warthog it makes no
sense that they're all the same size but
I guess I don't know science there's
also a man lurking behind has to do this
be the character Baxter Stockman
confirmed to be voiced by Giancarlo
Esposito in this film in Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle lore he is a scientist that
eventually gets mutated into a half man
half fly he might be the person behind
the ever important ooze and all of these
mutated creatures let me get a shot of
this mutant Kaiju it's awesome to behold
if you look closely it's made up of a
whole mix of animals it has bug eyes
mandibles a whole elephant's head with
tusks in a trunk where its nose should
be and a giraffe on its face remember
those missing giraffes from April's
board well that could be it it also has
a whale's mouth a crab claw for its
right hand its left hand is made up of
three narwhal attached to an arm it's an
amalgamation of animals plus it's
spewing ooze out of its mouth this thing
is Nightmare fuel pure pure nightmare
fuel the citizens in Times Square are
understandably shocked to see it among
those people in the crowd there is this
painted robot man probably collecting
tips from tourists just like you'd see
in our world it's clear that Superfly
and his crew want the mutants to rule
the world as Mondo Gekko says in his
European accent pepos they gots the good
plus slapping the best we get more
rooftop running that culminates at a
height Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles pose
in front of a full moon and their eyes
are fully whitened out with their masks
blowing in the wind very stylized in
comic book s and it's possibly even a
nod to the cover of the very first
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles comic shout
out Kevin Eastman and the other guy
whose Name Escapes Me Superfly says six
in the morning police at my door this is
Ice Cube floating the Ice-T song six in
the morning also there's a device in the
van that Superfly clearly wants we later
see Leo falling from this device with
some sort of glowing red McGuffin the
police take on these mutants with some
serious Tech like these futuristic light
up guns and what's with the mean looking
guy with an eye patch is this Casey
Jones's origin story come on hockey mask
Casey's nice he's got a fight with the
good guys splintering Parts some wisdom
on the turtles calling out their
attributes as they wield their iconic
weapons Michelangelo's heart as he spins
his nunchucks Donatello's wisdom as we
see the stickers he has on his boat
staff hey you want to make sure you know
which one's yours Raphael has bravery
and his sigh and of course Leonardo as
his honor and the Dual Katana Raphael
shares that he dreams about fighting
every night which is Brothers
appropriately address we get another
look at our mutant Kaiju as it kicks a
fuel tanker forcing the turtles to dive
out of the way are those shells flame
I sure hope so then we see them
driving what looks like an early version
of The Turtle van an iconic toy that
every kid wanted I actually had this toy
and if I'm not mistaken it it shot out
manhole cover they've made many versions
of it over the years and I'd head over
to eBay if it's uh pickling your fancy
to purchase now this one seems to be a
commandeered pizza delivery van as
Donatello drives we get the classic
Cowabunga and that's it for this Tubular
Turtle trailer so Cowabunga dudes this
movie can't come soon enough make sure
you follow us here at new rockstars for
all things mutant and Mayhem tell us why
you're excited for this film by adding
us on social media we'll keep you posted
as more news drops for these Turtle boys
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to this and all channels on
the new rockstars Network I'm partial to
the new break room Channel by the way
until then let's get the shell out of
here here
[Music]